[Music]
what can you say about dota that hasn't
been said before his victories are
numerous his feats made immortal and his
fans are zealous but the story of the ex
God isn't just one about his victory
over enemies on the server it's also
about his triumph over trolls outside
the game in the early days of csgo those
who made a name for himself let's say
about the first nine months to a year of
csgo
he was a top 5 player in the world he
was very very good even at the time
would obviously nip I'd get right in
that forest and then they had other
players who were doing very well
dossier was just below their level hltv
gave him the same cloud has Thorin
raking dozer the 4th best player in the
world in 2013 but back then he was still
just doja his prowess on the server was
undeniable but outside the game some
people may have thought less of him
based on his appearance he wasn't
handsome or athletic and it didn't even
really look like he was trying to be the
Oni plays what best-of-three Udyr why is
he always easy but that doesn't really
matter if you're an eSports athlete not
to your fans or your foot stuffers
there's three letters in Jackson eat the
God of all three kills it was only years
after dojin became a relevant force in
the CS scene that he was a subject of an
emerging on July 26th 2015
dojin team hellraisers was playing as
LGB in the offline qualifier for the
cologne 2015 major during a technical
pause the camera took a chance to pan
across each of the players when it came
across dojin doing this it was a moment
that didn't go unnoticed by fans or
casters that's it that's it just if we
can't go to be honest and with that a
meme was born but every good meme needs
a name and on the hltv page for that
match one user called doja a sex monster
three days after that another hltv user
made a forum post asking the
unsuspecting public if there was anyone
more sexy than sex gods OSHA the threat
only got five replies but from there the
mean spread across the cs community was
a tender for the meme laid out it only
needed a spark to combust but instead it
got a Molotov on October 24th 2015
caricature artist honker posted to
Twitter that he'd be live-streaming his
next piece his subject sex God dojo at
this point in time Nong Kerr had already
made a name for himself on the r /
global offensive csgo subreddit and the
final image of dojo and all his glory
was posted to Reddit the next day to the
tune of 1.5 hours in up votes this
effectively solidified was a sex god
moniker as the meme steadily grew in
popularity parallels were drawn to
another older CS meme
[Applause]
JW the pig csgo viewers will often spam
twitch chat and forums and reddit with
pig related insults whenever JW comes up
both memes were meant to mock the
physical appearances of their subjects
but while the sex Kagamine was on the
rise JW's me was on the decline
JW sort of took the fire out of his meme
in two ways firstly by embracing it
[ __ ] enjoy brother and secondly by
winning
the rise of the meme also came at a
difficult point in doges career he had
just missed his first ever csgo major
when he didn't qualify for the 2015
major yeah throughout this tournament
they have had their ups and downs and
this most certainly is the biggest down
of them all they're not gonna be headin
over for the major and he'd go on to
miss the cluj-napoca major when he left
hellraisers before the qualifier and
during all this you'd only see one thing
being written about doja at this point
doja had never acknowledged the meme on
social media but he had bigger things to
worry about he was forming a new csgo
team HS GG in late December HS GG
qualified for the CIS minor for the
columbus major and what quickly picked
up by gambit esports naturally the news
post was flooded with references to the
sex got me the meme spiked in popularity
again when gambit won the CIS minor and
then spiked again when they qualified
for the major dojo finally had a csgo
career back on track but it didn't
matter
his social media feeds were still filled
with references to the sex God meme a
meme that and it's heart was meant to
mock him from the gift to the caricature
and especially the term sex God itself
the mean was designed to mock doges less
than sex God of appearance regardless of
how dojo felt about the meme it was out
of his control at least until he
revealed his signature sticker for the
columbus major he signed it x god it was
a variation of the original sex god mean
but it was different he was taking
control of it on his own time five days
later Gambhir released a video featuring
an attractive russian girl who is
definitely no jizz girlfriend
featuring plenty of fan service and
titillation and two days later
gambit released another video featuring
an interviewer asking random people if
they knew who the X God was which of
course featured more pretty Russian
girls telling us they knew exactly who
he is
X got at doors
the videos were cheesy exploitative and
corny and dota himself initially wasn't
fond of them being filmed
but both videos picked up over three
million combined views on YouTube Gosha
and gambit took the meme and poured
gasoline on it but they did it by making
it their own from there as those who
became a bigger presence in csgo so to
to the persona of the ex god the meme
spiked in popularity when gambit
competed in the columbus major and when
they achieved the legend status at the
Cologne 2016 major and then again was
they maintained their legend status with
a win over faze clan at the Atlanta 2017
major but the biggest ever spike came
later when dojin company won the krakow
major thanks in large part to doges
incredible 200 IQ grenade
[Applause]
two months later at the height of the
xcode means popularity no jobs betrayed
the persona by marrying his actual
real-life girlfriend 2017 was probably
the most important year of both those
his career and his life but it put a bit
of a damper on his playboy alter ego and
then at the most recent major in Boston
gambit failed to defend their title and
retain their legend status fimo last
alive 15 found them gone fnatic 16 to
destroy the defending major champions
and ends their run here life you want to
call it a run gambit have yet to find a
strong fifth player to fill the hole
left by ex captain Zeus and there a big
question mark heading into the upcoming
London major despite that doshas legacy
remains strong he's the first and only
russian csgo player to win a major he's
one of the biggest prize earners in csgo
history and he's transformed a meme
meant to mock him into a rallying cry
for his true believers that is beautiful
almost as beautiful as the man himself
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button